Shut your eyes, cover your ears, and pinch
your nose, 'cause Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker
is going to turn your brain to goo and send
it leaking out of your head.
More specifically, the final shot of the upcoming
Star Wars flick will, quote, "melt your mind,"
according to diehard Star Wars fan and filmmaker
Kevin Smith.
Speaking with IGN during 2019's San Diego
Comic-Con, Smith recalled his experience on
the set of The Rise of Skywalker, where director
J.J. Abrams and the film's crew were sending
him mixed signals about a certain set piece
that is, the set piece used for the closing
shot of the film, and thus the final frame
of the entire Skywalker saga.
Smith detailed that some folks at Pinewood
Studios, where The Rise of Skywalker was being
filmed, advised him to not look at the final
shot set piece, as it's shocking enough to
anyone who sees it.
On the other hand, some people urged Smith
to take a peek at it for that same reason.
"There was a scuttlebutt about a set there
at Pinewood.
'You have to
see this, when you see this it will melt your
mind.'"
When Smith asked why, Abrams told him it was
the last shot of the movie.
"'You don't want to be spoiled.
You want to be in a theater when this happens,
trust me.'
And then other people on the crew were like,
'Bro, I wish I hadn't seen it.
I'm glad I did, but it will melt your mind.'"
Smith continued, noting that it was almost
impossible for him to resist the temptation
to look at the final shot of The Rise of Skywalker.
Ultimately, though, his will power was strong
enough, and Smith walked away from his time
on the film's set with confidence that whatever
The Rise of Skywalker ends on, it will be
incredible thanks to JJ Abrams.
He also underscored the importance of trusting
filmmakers and not cheating oneself out of
an amazing cinematic experience by looking
at spoilers.
"But J.J.'s such a magical magician that I'm
just like, 'You know what?
Do it, trick me.'
I'll wait and get tricked.
Even though I could've seen what it was, I
was like, 'I'll sit back.
I'll like your plan.'
He's never let me down so far.'"
What this final shot could be, we truly have
not a single clue.
But whatever it is, someone told Smith that
it's pretty impressive.
And that's...well, that's something, right?
It's definitely not nothing.
Okay, maybe it's only slightly better than
nothing.
Because let's remember: when it comes to all
things Star Wars, Kevin Smith is not what
you might call an "objective source."
Remember his first movie, Clerks, which featured
an extended discussion on the ethics of blowing
up the second Death Star in Return of the
Jedi, which was likely filled with contractors
working hard to finish construction:
"Think the average Stormtrooper knows how
to install a toilet main?
All's they know is killing in white uniforms."
Think back to his second feature film, Mallrats,
a movie in which his character, Silent Bob,
spent considerable screen time attempting
to master the Jedi Mind trick.
"Knock it off!"
"The Force is strong with this one."
"Dude, don't encourage him."
And then Chasing Amy, his third movie, actually
features a long rant about the racial politics
of the original Star Wars trilogy in the film's
first batch of scenes.
So while someone almost certainly told Smith
that watching that last scene would melt his
mind, it's important to remember some important
context: the crew-member was talking to Kevin
Smith.
There's no doubt that watching the scene would've
melted his mind.
"There are people in the world that know what
the last shot is, even if the movie's not
fully cut together at this point.
I'm not one of them."
But as for the rest of us?
Well, let's just hope that the final scene
will leave our brains at least lightly singed.
That's not too much to hope for, is it?
“AHHH!”
Prepare for a head-spinning experience when
Star Wars: The Rise of Skywalker arrives in
theaters on December 20.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.